my name is Ptolemy Lani and I live in
Los Angeles
I'm originally from Iran and I'm a
painter this show is called first light
and I'm thrilled to be showing this body
of work at MIT mist I've been thinking
about the idea of light and power or
control through lights in a few
different works I was really interested
in the idea of the smiley face to me
that he stands for some kind of a
culture of dogma so I was thinking about
wanting to project that onto a body of
people and I thought about the idea of
the light and the sublime and I kind of
religious experience in paintings that I
did the projector and the source of
light became really interesting the fact
that is sort of a medium now as opposed
to the light of God or enlightenment
it's the light of the projector and then
the idea was both who's projecting it
onto them in some of the works the
figure seems to be dealing with a kind
of a crisis there's some force claim on
it on its body
I do feel certain kinds of masculinity
are in crisis I mean I'm very aware that
I am painting in America right now there
is something very much about the current
condition of our cultures that doesn't
inform the work to find a way of
thinking about certain realities you
have to find different alleyways there's
a very strong history of satire and
caricature and also you know humor as a
brain process is
what separated us supposedly from the
Neanderthals in a way sort of to be
human is to be able to deal with things
with human and painting in general the
way I set up painting for myself has a
lot to do with play in a way I mean
video playing we paint with subjects and
humor always interests play so we're
showing two animations in the show and
the thing about animations is that it
takes about 1,700 images to make an
animation about it's about two minutes
so it's very good for sort of focusing
on one idea and I paint very fast so to
stay with a particular topic the
animations are very gratifying
you're painting a way that the speed at
which your brain works if you paint
let's go or than that it's too fast
first in your brain you you can't catch
it so you have to kind of find out what
works for your thinking process so for
me the way that was possible was by
being quite direct on the canvas is not
a pre-planned things anyway
compositional matters go out the window
because that's not for me the way that
it'll become a lot